blind the eyes that cannot see  make dafty ears that cannot hear close  the mouth that cannot tell  and send the monster back to hell back  then his name was roy huggins  when he was your age he already had a  taste for blood  holy [ __ ] what's happening  nothing will stop killroy if he wants to  get you  oh god you almost gave me a heart attack  i'm a middle-aged man who eats like [ __ ]  and huff's floor cleaner all day  this is alicio and ernesto  hola amigos namo father  come on out the online donations  have put us over the top it's going to  take a lot more  money for that heart transplant  keep killing boogie man that is just  some superstitious [ __ ]  i'll make my special sweet teeth  gonna come smoke  yes you see that the gator chaser did it  again  i'm coming to kilroy  [Music]  better get them all